this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
yes I'm going to have the opportunity to
introduce Peter then he's going to
introduce Jess a my name is Tom Byers
and I'm one of the instructors for the
entrepreneurial thought leader seminar
series and this is my first Wednesday
afternoon with you and I enjoy doing
this with my colleague Tina Seelig and
Tom kosnik and the whole crew you know
welcome to the draper fisher gervais and
entrepreneurial thought leaders seminar
series brought to you by the Stanford
Technology Ventures program and bases
the Business Association Stanford
entrepreneurial students the student of
this talk is archived in the future by
SCPD as well as online at simply Ecore
nur stanford.edu
Ecore nur stanford.edu the entire series
is generously underwritten by the
venture capital firm dfj so I get to
introduce Peter Fenton who's the one on
the left
Peter was a student here in the 1990s
and as an undergraduate as a philosophy
major which really makes me happy to
report a humanities major he goes on to
get an MBA here at Stanford and then
enters the venture capital industry
first seven years of being in that
industry was at a firm called accel
partners where you may have heard of
from Facebook and folks like that but
then about seven years six seven years
ago he became a partner at benchmark
capital and has been involved in a
tremendous number of hits in successes
there including Yelp and OpenTable and
others and something I know you've heard
about Twitter so without further ado let
me introduce you to Peter Peter
so Tom threw me a curveball and said a
couple weeks ago hey we've got a change
of plans can you fill in for the
gentleman from Ohio he couldn't make it
today
and yeah I thought the last thing you
guys want to hear from is another
venture capitalist and and so I tried to
put myself into your shoes and say you
know who would I want to have come talk
and that about a millisecond later just
Lee popped into my mind just had just
won the fortune forty hundred one of the
40 under 40 a camera or what number she
was but something approached in the 30s
maybe the 20s and they're really two
reasons the first is the Jess life like
myself sat in your seat on her case it
was eight years ago in 2004 top-class
she took this class I I crashed this
class a couple times but but justice is
what we affectionately call in our
industry a rising star and we spent a
lot of time idolizing the people who
have arrived and I think not enough time
studying people in their hands and their
ascendency to greatness and there's so
many things you can learn from a
first-time CEO and how they go about it
what's cool about jess is that it's
immediately accessible so she faced the
same questions the same challenges angst
and anxieties that you may face right
now in your career going into it and so
I thought what a perfect opportunity to
talk to one of the Rising Stars someone
will be writing books about I think
maybe in two or three decades and
they'll tribute back to this some of the
ideas back to what you might hear today
but but first let me spend a second on a
company just as part of Polyvore
benchmark invested in Polyvore and 2008
about the same time just joined the
company and it's very simple thesis
which is Polly Wars doing to the fashion
magazine industry what wikipedia has
done to the Encyclopedia Brittanica it
is truly the creative destruction of a
existing industry with a modern
empowered consumer model which i think
is going to change every category of
media that we know it's happened at at
Wikipedia at Yelp at TripAdvisor at IMDB
and Pali boards doing it in the fashion
market so what does that mean well
there's a value chain in any industry
and in the media industry the value
was content editorial distribution
advertising and long came the internet
and we gave people a voice instead of
content being this you know creative
types yet that wear turtlenecks that you
have to pay a lot of money to it was the
community in empowering the community
and giving them a voice instead of a
value chain it created a set of
concentric circles where at the center
of it there is a human being creating
beautiful content that community curated
the content and they curate that a Polly
Ward Yelp but at Wikipedia and that
draws in the readership so instead of
having to print magazines and push them
out on shelves people naturally come to
your site either through Google or they
download your application and then
monetization the really powerful thing
is that the advertising is actually
endemic to the experience so the ad is
the content so probably war is an
example one of the companies I think
will look back on and you look at Vogue
InStyle
lucky cosmopolitan all collapsed into
one company so the numbers are
compelling a company has double-digit
millions of revenue it's got triple
digit growth its cashflow positive and
so it's one of these rising success
stories probably doesn't get as much
press as Pinterest the ink companies are
different but the structural advantages
of business leaders to think about a
multi-billion dollar company and that
the story of just becoming CEO will
spend a little bit of time on but it's
one of those magical stories in my
career where there was an act of
selflessness from Pasha the then CEO and
now CTO the company co-founder of a
chess really selflessness combined with
a deep ambition about the company's
long-term opportunity and Pasha called
me well in about this time last year in
2010 and said for 2011 it said had kind
of kind of a an idea you may or may not
like kind of a crazy idea what if we
make just the CEO and as a director
you're like oh what's going on you know
you're disoriented you're trying to
figure out okay how do I help Pasha
what's he had a bad day and um and I
thought about it in it was like thinking
about just for today it was immediately
obvious and within moments the board
unanimously once they found out had the
same reaction I did within moments it
was clear that just was the nap
CEO of the company and a lot of what we
do in the venture business is
identifying the potentials of the CEO
because we typically back first-time
CEOs people haven't done it before and I
would assert there's three traits that
that really define in my experience the
successful first-time CEO and their
visible and jess and hopefully we'll
hear about someone today the first which
we'd seen in our experience working with
her is that just as they learn it all
and not a know-it-all and it's
challenging when you get into a CEO role
you job no one's if it's the first time
see I've never done it before and if
you're a know-it-all you can immediately
think you have to have the answer for
everything and you can't ask for input
and advice you quickly get in the water
way over your head and you're likely to
drown and and and Jess had proven to us
that she knew how to raise her hand and
ask questions but she was a sponge
French for information I saw the same
thing by the way at Excel we we spent
time with Mark Zuckerberg the beginning
voracious appetite to learn the second
trait which i think is quite rare in
human beings is it clear aptitude at
building the system that builds the
system and oftentimes if you're a VP in
a company you focus on your narrow area
and you just say okay I'm going to do my
job I'm the player on the field I'm
going to crush it very rarely do you get
somebody says how does my job relate to
all the other jobs in the company and
what's the operating system of the
business and ingests had shown to us
that she had a way to think about that
at a more broad level because as a CEO
you no longer evaluated are you a good
VP of X Y or Z you're evaluated on the
underlying system that you've built Jack
Dorsey likes to say you know his his
focus is on building the product that is
the company not the product that is the
thing that gets shipped every day of
course that's a byproduct of it but
ingest just to demonstrate an aptitude
through her ability to identify parts of
the company that weren't working well
identifying friction points trying to
remove those friction points and so a
clear trait of a successful first time
CEO the third thing which to me is the
romantic thing the visionary thing the
thing I'm most drawn to is a clarity of
purpose it just said to me we talked we
were having some conversations of you
know does she want to do this or not and
when she talked about Polyvore she
started with the people in the community
whose lives were changed
and it was never about Jess it was about
this is a service that is taking people
in Des Moines taking people in Rio de
Janeiro turning them into the vanguard
in the fashion industry they could never
do this without Polly Ford in the
purpose and mission of the company of
empowering people to transform the way
they discover fashion the way they buy
fashion bully that was magnetic and you
know you've heard about this from other
people who come here and so you have to
tell story at a company you need an epic
story that draws people and it's the way
Jack talks about it
the CEO is the editor-in-chief and if
they don't have a clarity of purpose and
ability to motivate and inspire what's
possible what have happened what happens
if we get it right and and just had done
that there's a great if you guys ever
get a chance goggle her for a New Yorker
article just had a there was a Polly for
article in New Yorker because we have s
in the company say hey one day someone's
going to write a story about this
company it talks about some people whose
lives you've turned you've changed you
transformed because today to get ahead
at Vogue you got to go play politics on
Madison Avenue backstab maybe but let's
just say you know climb your way to the
top and where someone sitting in a you
know room you know in the Midwest that
has a fantastic fashion sensibility is
just shut out of the dialogue your
companies change them and people are
going to want to write about that and
suggest in that story she wasn't the CEO
at the time the story was really about
about Jess even though it was about
Polly torso those three traits I think
you know you can go to all the different
skills of the CEO some of our execution
oriented some are you know great
relationship people some are great
visionaries just was the full package
from our standpoint is the first time
CEO the brief background then we'll jump
into some questions she was born in Hong
Kong came to Stanford in 2000 and went
to Larkin was her name from Larkin and
had their freshman dorm so you know
again took this class graduating from
computer science in 2004 then faced the
big choice of what next went to Google
was a sensational product manager and
I'd first heard about Jess from Brett
Taylor who was this recently the CTO at
Facebook and Brett said when he started
his company FriendFeed there's one
person we have to hire out of Google
it's Jess leak so that's that's great
but she just contacted another
investment we made and asked for a job
and so um which was Polyvore so is one
of these serendipitous moments but I you
know Brett maybe still hasn't forgiven
me and as I say she's been identified by
a number of people in our world is at
thirty years old one of the truly great
rising star CEOs and so it'll be really
fun set of questions today's you guys
think about your own careers and the
questions they just face and how she
answered them I think there's a high
relevance so with that welcome Jose and
so let me ask you start with the
question of when you were in this seat
in 2004 did you imagine you would be up
here at some point
No so my background so I like Peter
mentioned I I grew up in in Hong Kong
and I actually in my senior of high
school I told my parents like hey I want
to go to art school I'm gonna draw comic
books for a living and my parents said
no no way they're Asian so that was not
a acceptable life choice so I ended up
coming to Stanford and I ended up
majoring in computer science because I
discovered I really liked to build
things that people could use my favorite
class here with CS 2:48 the graphics
video game class and then I ended up at
Google I sort of became a product
manager I was doing you know basically
using my my engineering degree as a
product manager then but then one day
someone showed me Polyvore and it was
just sort of like love at first sight so
I mean I didn't come up with the
original idea for Polyvore all the
credit goes to my three co-founders
Pasha Guang Mei and joining they posh in
particular came up with the idea he
started to build it they launched
something and then someone showed me the
site and I was just completely in love I
was playing with it two or three hours
at night just hopelessly hopelessly
addicted and then you know I I sent an
email to posh I didn't know him at the
time I just said hey this site is
incredible I have a lot of ideas some
suggestions I wasn't actually asking for
a job but I just you just quoted a user
like writing in complaining about stuff
so I wrote my list of companies not you
and I was there begging for a job and
then he wrote back and said hey why
don't we get coffee and so we met for
coffee and then we all clicked and then
I sort of ended up leaving Google and I
never imagined that I would hear yeah
never I mean I went into it thinking
okay
I've always wanted to be a blogs wanted
to do a start-up my mom happens to be an
entrepreneur
she runs a small interpretation
translation business in Hong Kong so
very small business but I always knew I
wanted to do my own thing and I thought
hey Polyvore is just a way for me to
learn about startups I mean I learned a
lot at Google but the rate of learning
sort of went down as I got more and more
used to what I was doing there and
company got bigger so I thought okay
this would be a way that I will learn
everything I need about startup and then
I'll go do my own thing and then it
became my own thing so I mean I didn't I
wasn't there from the very beginning of
Polyvore but the other three founders
they sort of made me an honorary
co-founder after a couple of years
because we just I mean we did everything
together from the very beginning you
know when there was we were working out
of Pasha's living room and you know
finally we had to find an office like
finding an office space like the toilet
breaks and everything water is
overflowing like every little thing you
have to deal with in the early days of a
start-up we just you know how to do that
together
so going back to the decision to go to
Google I suppose a lot of people
wondered you go to a startup or do you
go to a established company no for
Google's not yet public or about to go
public it wasn't public at the time okay
so is it slightly before slightly before
but probably you knew it was gonna gonna
be a good company um tell us about that
decision in whether or not in hindsight
you think it was the right the right
move and I guess along those lines
mentors you found at Google and how they
impacted your your career sure um so I
actually what I finished when I
graduated or right before I graduated
peer with a degree in computer science I
thought hey I'm gonna be an engineer
that's what computer science majors do
and I didn't even know what a product
manager was at that time so I got an
offer from Intuit and I was going to go
be an engineer there and then I got a
call from a Google recruiter saying hey
we have this thing called the associate
product manager program which I highly
recommend if anyone's thinking about
that path and it was a Polyvore
associate program but it was a program
to Train product manager straight out of
school and it was created by Marissa
Mayer who's now the CEO of Yahoo and so
I thought okay you know I'll give it a
shot I don't know what PMS are I wanted
the interview not really knowing what to
expect and I remember I actually was so
green
the time that when I spoke to Marissa I
was like hey I don't know if I really
want this job like this is very I never
imagined that I would do this and she
explained to me that all the best
decisions she had ever made in life when
she had to choose between two things she
always chose the path that was more
challenging as I thought about that and
I decided hey you know what I've always
planned to be an engineer but this p.m.
thing sounds really hard I have to be
teams of engineers who were much older
than me who know their know their stuff
and I don't I'm fresh out of school so I
decided to just to try it based on her
advice and she did become a mentor and
has sort of kept in touch all these
years and she was a big big influence on
my entire career path through Google
yeah um I I look back on that and I
think well I could have started maybe
had a startup out of school but the
great thing that being at Google
provided was oh there's a few things one
I got to meet a lot of really really
smart people some of whom you know have
gone on to do amazing things in Silicon
Valley and some of whom I've gotten to
join Polyvore we work together so you
sort of build your network at a larger
company the other thing is just the
experience of being at a larger company
and seeing all the benefits which are
having infrastructure you know there's
an IT guy to help you when everything is
you know your computer everything is
broken the network's down the great
perks of Kult the culture the food all
that stuff I got to experience that and
Google does have a really really great
culture it's very engineering driven but
then I also got to experience the
downsides of a big company like red tape
bureaucracy having to work the system to
get launches approved so I got to see
both sides and then I was able to take
that experience and apply it at poly war
when we were creating our own culture
and our own sort of infrastructure it
made me really able to appreciate how
nice it is to be on a really small team
or you just get stuff done really
quickly there's no communication
overhead we know everybody in everyone
significant others like all the great
things about startups that are small I I
was able to appreciate that so much more
because I'd been at a larger company in
part of my one of the benchmarks
founding partners Andy right cliff has a
great post on this which is that people
going to a successful company like a
Google you know called midlife about to
go public or just went public tend to
get more credit than they deserve for
the success of the company and those
that go to a start-up company where it
fails they tend to get more
Naser so being to put another way I
think the move if you think of it in
developing a career of going to a
success story they're actually far fewer
ways to succeed in my experience in
their to fail and I'm not clear what you
learned from failure even if they're
certain personal lessons you get out of
it but success is its own unique breed
of than education
and going to a successful company and
today you could say they'd be a Dropbox
or Twitter or one could argue as
Facebook passed that point I don't know
but I think it's a pretty good proxy for
you know getting experience of
hyperscale successful you know culture
and you internalize that in theory that
the flip side is staying there too long
and you know oftentimes you stay
somewhere too long you can start to get
the groundwater gets into your your
being where you start to assume
everything as sort of like Google and so
I want to talk a little bit about that
transition because it's a pretty abrupt
shift to go from you know the
high-flying Google to the backed up
toilet Polygram yeah and did you just
the the decision itself did you did you
fret over it and I know you didn't come
over overnight because he seemed to wait
about six hours and so how did you think
about that transition and maybe you know
what did it feel like for the first
phase being in a in a raw story yeah um
so the two things that I was thinking
about were you know I want to go to some
work on something that I'm passionate
about and I was already so addicted to
Pauls I was using it like literally two
or three hours a night I was a member of
the community making lots of sets our
collages um so that was one thing that
that checked that box the other thing
was I wanted to go besides like always
picking the more challenging path the
other thing that I find useful is to
think about maximizing your learning and
I knew that I'd learned a lot I learned
so much in my first year at Google like
I had never led any teams like I had
poor communications good all sorts of
things I learned in my first year at
Google but then the rate of learning
sort of tapered off and so I decided
okay I need to go somewhere where I'm
going to learn so much all at once and
Polyvore by virtue of being so small and
only having you know engineers I knew
there was gonna be a ton of things to
learn like we needed to do a lot of
things we needed to find an office space
we needed to create a revenue model and
I just knew that there would be space
and freedom and opportunity for me to do
some of those things there so that's why
I ended up choosing Pali but it wasn't
an easy decision I remember when I went
to sign the offer on that day I was like
what am i doing I'm a decision and then
I signed it I walked out as I go no what
did I just do
that wasn't you know crystal clear but
it was like one of the best decisions
I've ever made for sure did you ever in
that first phase of acclimating I think
you made a big mistake
no I actually have never thought that
about Polly or there's always been
enough positive moment I mean it hasn't
all been you know you read about a lot
of companies in TechCrunch and you think
wow it's all up in to the right and it's
so easy it's not easy like even when
things are going well there's like still
lots of moments of unhappiness actually
just wrote a blog post about this why
startup founders are always so unhappy
if you want to check it out but yeah I
mean it's it's definitely it was
definitely hard and in the beginning but
in the beginning it was hard and we had
no traction and we were small but at the
same time it was so fun to just
continually learn things I was so
excited to learn about Mountain View
real estate prices versus Palo Alto and
you know that just made it sort of that
sustained it sustained me and then I
realized after some time maybe I should
have hired a professional to do some of
these things and focus on the things
that mattered more but you know i i've
immensely enjoyed all of polymorph
fantastic so let's talk a little bit
about the transition to CEO and one of
the just just to call out and Justices
mentioned that she's a honorary founder
just as the founder of poli where
there's no question i think one of the
things that we you know jack dorsey
spoken of this we tend to use the term
as though it has some sort of magical
power like well if your founder than
like you know everything is different
but bro human beings and we all are
founders in our own way of things
initiatives things to take on and I
think it gets overly sensationalized and
just was from the beginning the soul of
the product you know I think it was very
clear to us you know as we talked about
her becoming a co-founder like well of
course she's a co-founder the company
actually aggressively pushed equity onto
just to reflect that which I thought was
very this is after the fact really the
luster of the culture the company has
but the transition to CEO is a big one
in you know the statistics are most
people don't make
successfully I don't want to jinx it so
knock on wood but you've you really in a
way that I haven't seen in my venture
career taken to the role could you tell
us about how it's different and you know
a little bit about where did you want
the role and now that you're in it you
know how does it change your world well
so one of my co-founders and I Pasha
like we have always done a lot of like
done a lot of the leadership together
like and we've sort of found our natural
niches for what we were good at like
Peter gives me too much credit like I
think I am one of the users of the site
like I like you know I like to shop I
like fashion so I think about the
product that way but what Pasha's
brilliant at is designing architecting
systems and thinking about like the
feedback loops and just sort of the way
the product works from a systems design
perspective so I think the combination
of those two things is really the soul
of what made Polyvore product take off
in terms of the the transition the way
we'd always split responsibilities was
you know he was responsible for
engineering I was our product manager
but he's also a brilliant product guy
but we as we started to add more people
to the team like we added a sales team
we added no finance and people
operations recruiting it just naturally
fell to me that those people just ended
up reporting in to me and engineering
was reporting in to him and so as we
grew and the other parts of the company
grew just became more of a natural
transition and it's exactly what Peter
was referring to it's about the company
becomes the product not just the product
you know the website or the app but I I
really realize both of us passion I that
the role of the CEO is shifting from
being less about just building the
product but building team that builds
the product and so that naturally became
more my purview I was always one of
always recruiting for us so it felt like
a pretty natural transition and we
discussed it and we decided alright
let's do it but I never went into poly
whatever expecting this to happen um
yeah it's interesting thing which just
makes the comment she's like I wasn't
looking for this and I there if I could
be simple about it they're kind of two
types of people that come to this the
role CEO those that want to be CEO and
those that if you will earn the title
and I think founders inherent
when they're founder CEOs are in the
title because they took the initiative
but it's a red flag for us as venture
capitalists when so much owes up at our
office and says I'm really ready to be a
CEO so I'm looking for CEO opportunities
oh well that's great you're going to
because you're going to diverse select
into the broken companies that are
looking for a CEO and there was
something very natural digest as
evolution to the role because it sort of
was happening as the course of how she
was scaling inside of the company and I
am Bishan to be a CEO is a is can be a
dangerous thing but I actually curious
as you think about now you're in the
role how is it different than maybe you
wear your roles before and what's on
what's been unexpected yeah well you
know I think the role of the CEO
definitely changes as the company gets
larger right and I went into this
assuming like okay there's a set of
things we need to do in the next I don't
know at least a year maybe two years
three years that I think I can do I
think I know how to do these things or I
can learn some of them but I also went
into it thinking like there may be a
point at which I might not be the right
CEO anymore like maybe taking the
company public requires a different sort
of person so I definitely went in with
it that way so I agree like you don't
want to just be like I don't have to be
the CEO it's about what does a company
need and what are you actually good at
and this was sort of the right period
for me um things that have been
unexpected uh I thought I would be able
to spend a lot more time working on the
product uh in addition to doing a lot of
the other duties that's turned out to be
not the case I spend so much of my time
recruiting and meeting and thinking
about architecting the right team to get
what we've done we need done so that's
been a little bit surprising as a
control freak it's been difficult
sometimes to let go of some of the
product responsibly I was the VP of
Product before that we have an awesome
PM Rachel who like it took me it took us
a while to figure out how to you know
delegate how to let things go but I
think we've we've we've gotten that down
so that's been that's been surprising um
oh the amount of external stuff that I
have to do is also been a little
surprising I'm more of an introvert by
nature so having to do that is not the
most natural thing but it comes up a lot
so it's something you just sort of have
to push and do
yeah how about your priorities and so
part of this is a bit of a day in the
life how do you think about your week
your your you know any period of time in
as a CEO how do you think about studying
those priorities hmm well we have a
strategic set of priorities for the
company and you know there are parts of
the things that are going very very well
that don't need attention the important
thing is I think you want to design the
company to operate like as a series of
like blocks that work well and spin on
their own and have api's to the other
kind of so you know I look for the parts
that are not you know that need
attention or need help and try to spend
my time there helping and that might
mean adding a new person or change it uh
changing a new process or it might be
the interface between two teams it's not
corrective to rewrite the API uh but a
lot of the time now I'm spending on
recruiting and just building parts of
the team that aren't there yet like
we've Polyvore has product and
engineering we've got a sales team but
we're actually missing a few functions
like we don't have a marketing team we
don't have PR and that is you know we've
always done our marketing and growth
through our community which is a very
powerful tool or powerful force like
they go and tell their friends about the
site that's how we've grown but now
thinking about that being a function
like how do we build that searching for
we found a CFO like a lot of a lot of
the time just goes there but I try to
figure out where I'm needed and then
always make sure to pay some attention
to product because that's a probably
thing I'm strongest at yeah and I think
it's that building the system there's
editing the team people have used that
as it you know sometimes you make the
right right hire some time to make the
wrong harness and it's it's a really
different role let me come back to if
you were to introspect in the
development of your career and some
mistakes that you've made that would be
instructive maybe for the group to learn
from um anything that stands out oh so
many um one of the biggest mistakes I
probably made early on was not talking
to other entrepreneurs at all I was you
know heads down working really hard I
just every problem that we had we sort
of dealt with internally
and I think that can be a big mistake
because the only external data points
you have about other companies are like
things you read about on TechCrunch
where everything seems to be doing great
you know it's all the positive stories
I'll just spin all the overnight success
stories at that time Korah wasn't around
so I didn't have that as a resource I
remember I looked at Marc Andreessen
blog that was probably one of the best
resources but I was very insular and so
I didn't realize like I didn't have
enough perspective to know like oh the
company is actually doing fine in fact
we're doing better than many of the
other startups out there or this problem
that I have that feels like the end of
the world is actually something that
many other companies have gone through
and survived or - and super common like
everybody has that problem like I didn't
even realize that every time someone
left the company I thought oh my god
it's this is terrible this must mean
we're screwing something up and now I
realize that's a natural part of how
companies evolved so that was a big
mistake when I started to talk to other
entrepreneurs it was great for my mental
health as well as for getting data
points solutions ideas on how to fix
things so that was a big big mistake I
think I made in the beginning other
things a common thing a common mistake I
think most entrepreneurs make is being
too slow to have someone leave like you
just want to you know you've invested in
bringing someone on they've left their
awesome job at Google or Yahoo or
somewhere else to join you and it's not
working for some reason it might be roll
fit it might be culture fit you just
keep trying to make it work because you
kind of you made a commitment to them
and they made a commitment to you and
you know sometimes it's just not a fit
and you just need to move on and it's
better for them in the long run and it's
better for you and that that was a hard
lesson - the Egyptian gears again and
we'll get to audience questions but part
of the CEOs job is the paint a vision of
the future the company and I'd love to
hear and I think God is benefit from
hearing the view what's the future for
poly boilerplate and in what do you
visualize is success for the company
yeah so Peter talked about the fashion
magazine side of Polyvore there's
another sort of trend that we we track
nicely against which i think is the
evolution of e-commerce so if you think
about how e-commerce came about on the
web it was driven by categories like
electronics so buying a digital camera
and the way you think about buying a
digital camera
what's very research-driven you care
about hard numbers and attributes like
number of megapixels or price and
because of that the e-commerce
experience the standard e-commerce
experience is a search box and then a
set of filters like digital camera
refined by 10 to 16 megapixels under
$500 and then you start to look at the
reviews and that's if you whether you're
looking at a clothing side or anything
on Amazon com that's sort of the
standard UI but there's actually a whole
category of goods that you just don't
buy that way like I I have this I bought
this shirt it's like a specific color
it's got actually got a huge hole in the
back which is kind of impractical but I
just like it that's my taste I like the
shirt and I like the particular brand
that it came from so I'm buying this
shirt based on my personal taste which
is incredibly arbitrary and based on
trends that evolve over time like I'm
sure this shirt will be extremely uncool
in 10 years or 2 years I don't know but
it'd be cool again in 10 years that's
right yeah but you know taste is always
evolving so I think there's a category
of products that you buy based on taste
and at probably where we're trying to
understand people's tastes so when
people mix and match products they like
that's them giving us data saying hey
this product is cool these two products
go together we can extract from that a
trend the whole in the back of your
shirt trend or whatever and we can track
that over time so it's actually our
community is giving us tons and tons of
data about taste and from there we can
do all kinds of things like build a
better shopping experience that's more
discovery and browser-based
have friends recommend to friends what
they're buying and and so that's sort of
the what I see is the evolution of
polygons it doesn't just apply to
fashion it's also you know the way you
buy a sofa or wall decor wedding items
but I think there's actually a lot of
categories of products that fall into
this so that's sort of where I see the
product vision going I've been really
moved by the community you've built and
some of the stories that come out of
that I'd love to hear your description
of the community and calm users but
they're not really users they're the
creators on the site and some of the
personal stories that come out of that
yeah so I think what people don't
necessarily realize is when you look at
polygons why people are making all these
cool
Jassi sets you know there some people
think oh they're you know shopping for
themselves they're creating a
personalized wish list of things that
they want that's not what they're doing
it's actually a form of self-expression
I think especially for women what you're
wearing is sort of a next you know an
extension of who you are sort of it's a
form of self-expression so a lot of
these people are on this site for
creative reasons for self-expression
reasons and they're making friends and
building a community so we've heard all
kinds of interesting stories from people
in the community who become friends we
recently had a meet-up in New York we
flew members from eleven members from
Brazil France all over the US Canada you
know someone who had she was from a
small town in in Canada and she'd never
been in she never ridden in a taxi
before we brought it to New York for
Fashion's Night Out which is a big sort
of party on the streets of New York
right before Fashion Week you know limo
ride take her to the hotel of great
breakfast with everybody and then just
seeing the stories that came out of that
was was really incredible like people
saying you know I use Polyvore as a form
of self-expression when my father passed
away you know it was a way for me to
sort of get therapy was and support for
the from the other members or people
making friends and one girl said you
know I've actually I met someone on the
site who I'm inviting to my wedding and
that's the first time where we're going
to meet so it's really amazing when you
when you give people tools to express
themselves and the ability to connect
they really form these super strong
relationships and it doesn't have to be
through Facebook they don't have to
actually know each other that well but
you just sort of in the self-expression
environment build real bonds and that's
sort of what's happened with our commune
we pay a lot of attention to community
management we have a great community
manager Nadia who actually talks to the
members and meets them and when their
issues you know sometimes she'll call
them we've sent flowers to people we've
had someone who was she was very ill and
we found her blog and we found a sweater
that she wanted so we bought her the
sweater and we made a cup when we
printed her Polyvore set on it and we
sent it to her and you know that's
that's she was really touched your whole
family sent us like a handwritten card
like little things like that those
little touches a little human touches
make a lot of difference yeah yeah yeah
at a board meeting the last board
meeting we had that Jess showed us a
video of the community members they flew
to New York and I think all of us were
it brought to tears at the you
underestimate
the impact of empowerment on people we
are given a voice where they didn't have
a voice and way to self express it
shapes who they are
it's then the Maslow hierarchy it needs
you at the very tip of the pyramid and
they all had just such love for polypore
and they were saying thank you and like
if you're an investor you say well these
are the people creating the content we
don't not only do we not pay them there
they're madly in love with the company
and yet they're building the company so
it's it's part of the future of a lot of
products in tapping into that creative
power harnessing it but making it and we
see the same thing at Yelp Wikipedia
never ceases to amaze me the Wikipedians
it's been I talked to Jimmy Wales the
beginning in 2002-2003
to try and invest in Wikipedia he
laughed at me he's like the last time we
tried to invest in Wikipedia we killed
it because that they they financed it as
a company and then they quicks it didn't
work and then the community took over
and then it became Wikipedia and there
are people that were spending hundreds
of hours a month curating at for no
other you know value than the sense of
connectedness and greater good that it
brought to you so a great product
experience is in touch with that and I
think it's one of the really powerful
things that you've had going in Polyvore
the last question I want to ask before
shifting gears getting questions from
the audience now I'm on your board and
is this is a lock word ask this question
but how do you think about us the the
board you the venture investor is
examine smart and and whereas the CEO
you sort of sit in between a lot of
different concentric circles and
integrating them how do you think about
us then maybe you know describe the
relationship for the audience going to
be pretty interesting and I can I can
dispute all the stuff um so you know
part of being a first-time entrepreneur
I never actually knew what to expect
from a board and so we've always had a
great relationship and it wasn't
actually till very recently we had an
experienced CFO join us and she's been
CFO in for 15 years and she's been on
lots of boards and she came to our board
me and she's like you have no idea how
awesome your boarded they're so you know
thoughtful strategic you know they're on
the same page like they don't you know
give you they give advice just at right
just the right level and I I guess I
didn't even realize I've yeah I mean I
think our board has always been
incredibly supportive I think the
important thing is is knowing what your
entrepreneur is good at and where to
leave them to do their magic in the one
area that's probably one area that
they're good at and then how to get them
help right and I think Peters always
been really good at identifying like ok
you guys I'm not gonna tell you how to
run the product or engineering you seem
to be doing a good job there but have
you thought about this as a revenue
model or have you talked to this person
so a lot of the introductions and new
relationships that kind of stuff has
always been really helpful also our
board has been incredibly helpful with
recruiting like Peter often takes the
time to meet some of the VP candidates
that were doing he's great at closing
and selling is you could see he sold me
pretty amazing so he's always very
helpful with that yeah it's uh she's too
kind I mean boards particularly at a
company like this when we invested it
had three people for the first phase I
would say you think about do no harm
and you know we don't boards don't make
companies they don't they can break
companies for sure and for that first 18
24 months we didn't really have board
meetings in the classic sense there
wasn't really an operating plan there
wasn't any other kind of classic stuff
because you have a little flicker of a
flame if you try and put the structure
that we have it's a like the Twitter
board where there's a real
infrastructure the board materials go
out week in advance it's a really
discipline that wouldn't have been
appropriate and so a big part of a
company I think what jess is going
through which is willing to be fun for
all of you to watch her skills to CEO
company and 30 people is radically
different than a company at 150 in that
that you know well 3 to 30 is a huge
leap but but 30 to 150 which is the
trajectory you're on means you get to a
point you don't know I run a company you
have to really obsess on building the
system that builds the system
look for friction points try and remove
them and that's very different than the
very at the beginning where at the
beginning you're trying to do things
quickly have experiments not be
bureaucratic and in some degree of
process has to come in when you get 250
people that didn't exist at 30 and
that's where a board I think I hope you
know we become more effective at saying
okay there's certain things you want to
recruit in expertise you know if you're
you know if you're in the credit
business you you probably want to if
you're doing payments you probably want
to recruit in someone who's an expert at
fraud if you're doing e-commerce you
probably want to recruit in somebody's
an expert Global Logistics the things
that you know
and I think in a start-up you know the
finance function you know you can
innovate around it but you know Cheryl
the person they recruited would've been
the CFO and AdMob and there's a there's
an equation and recruiting Cheryl that I
remember which is you know at first
blush she's like well I was at AdMob you
know who are you this company I've never
heard of him and you have to have the
confidence and belief in yourself as and
just had this and to say when Cheryl
spends enough time here she can't not
come she'll be so seduced by what we've
created and Chelsea yeah no I don't
think so and and we didn't quit there's
a great story we said well let's let's
do an interim role and because we all
had this confidence in the company that
if she spends three months in the
company she won't be able to leave and I
think was about two months and maybe
twenty days you know she called up and
said okay I'm gonna join but it wasn't
it wasn't easy to get me but let me
shift gears to actually one last
question for you advice in in if you
were to rewind the clock put yourself
into this audience anything that we
haven't talked about that you wish you'd
known and that you can impart his wisdom
to the people in front yeah um well I
would repeat some of the things I had
said already like take the more
challenging time you know optimize for
learning as much as possible um the
other thing which has become a company
mantra at Polyvore is do a few things
well if you're gonna start your own
thing you know maybe you have a grand
grand vision of like all the different
features its gonna have and all the
different you know revenue lines you're
gonna do and you know keep keep that
vision but do one piece of that first
and do it really really really well it's
so much better to do a few things well
then many things poorly for Polyvore the
very first thing that we did was the
Polyvore editor which is a tool where
you mix and match and you can create the
collages and there were actually other
companies at the time and there still
are there's probably 40 people 40
different companies out there that have
a Polyvore editor but we just focused on
building that and making that experience
really fun and really addictive and
really fast and smooth and that was what
brought users in and then we added more
features but if you have a crappy editor
feature and a crappy you know profile
and all these other features that are
just not that good or a little bit too
slow or clunky like you will lose you
will bleed users so just really really
focus on do
like identify the one thing that matters
and just make it as great as possible
like polish all the details I'd
amplifier that point it's lost in a lot
of education and entrepreneurship the
benefit of hyper focus because it comes
across as being excessively narrow and
there's this tension of well if you're
that focus don't you're supposed to go
after big opportunities and if you
perfect the editor you know is that is
that going to be the transformational
social commerce company and the stories
behind every one of the success stories
that I can relate to be at Facebook
hyper focus on the college market
probably we're focused on the niches
that you guys started in Yelp focused on
27 year olds in San Francisco writing
restaurant reviews their competitors
were doing the 27 million local
businesses all had a home page day one
let's light up the whole network and
Yelp so let's just do this really well
and building on success is a lot easier
than trying to you know boil the ocean
whatever term you want to use in
compounding on success name in that
internal culture your disciplined about
it defines I think so many of the
success stories from the losers in the
category well let me shift to the
audience and I thought of wait I thought
of two more things
oh one don't go it alone I'm really
really lucky to have an awesome set of
founders that I work with like I don't
know what I would do without them like
it's it's hard it's really hard you go
through all these crazy ups and downs
and everything feels like it's like you
know agony and then ecstasy and you want
someone you need a partner to go through
that with because otherwise they'll just
you'll you know go insane the the other
thing is just if you don't have an idea
like I've seen a lot of this I we've
seen a lot of this lately where I just
want to be a be out of startup I just
want a co-founder company I'm just gonna
do something I'm gonna quit my job and
just do something but if you don't have
an idea that you're passionate about
it's actually really hard to get through
those ups and downs like you will just
discard the idea immediately if you
don't feel really strongly about it so
if you don't have that idea yet keep
thinking about it but in the meantime go
do something productive like go to
another startup and learn at least start
learning like how they run it learn you
know how to manage a P&L or how to be a
product manager just go do something
rather than try to sit in a room with a
white board with your co-founder and a
computer like being like all right
what's our ideas like
I think I think that's really hard the
falling in love with the purpose of a
company it's the I see people go from
human to superhuman when that happens
and I think when you you fell in love
before you came so it's very much you
were you know that sense of founder of
the core mission but when you recruit
people and they you're in touch there's
a lot of talk of the why the how and the
what of a company and a really great
company spent a lot of time on why do
you exist and those questions of why are
we doing this be surprised how many
people answer it with a blank stare well
I wanted to do is start up I want to be
an entrepreneur one versus the answers
you get from Jeff Bezos or you know from
from you or from you know I love
Twitter's wife you know Twitter brings
you closer and they have that's a very
expansive idea what we don't finish that
sentence we let our users finish that
and as is compounding sense if that's
the emotion of the company and it's it's
sometimes easy to make it more
mechanical and say okay well this is
what one does with us or a company I
lose the magic and when it's there it's
amazing you start to close candidates II
don't think you can close you continue
to work long hours and feel a sense of
directions let me open it up for
questions and yeah if you're great
artists again just as we - my question
is I want to board up our flips and at
Mobius said a lot of tensions arise
Pocomoke founders and also even among
board members from time to time on
different directions so I wanted to ask
you Jess in your role how youth able to
moderate disputes or heated differences
a lot of founders they believe in that
one Peter on your side with other board
members and it is tough here it will ask
apiece how you've been able to resolve
some of those issues so the repeat the
question come for Jason for me how do we
deal with resolving conflict and
tensions that exist between founders and
other directors and maybe founders -
yeah I mean we've definitely had sets of
strategic disagreements at the company
when it's between the founders like it's
it's harder because you both have to be
there right if it's from a new executive
you're going to hire you can actually
screen for a lot of those things like if
they say hey I think the direction of
the company should be this and you're
like wait wait wait wait that's we don't
want to become you know we don't want to
carry inventory and ship stuff to a poly
board members you can screen for that
ahead of time but when it's for the
founders that's a little bit more
difficult so we
at the end of the day I think you have
to be on the same page to the rest of
the company right so you have to have a
unified front one thing we've tried is
and it doesn't really happen that often
but like what's an example maybe how
when we were earlier days like how we
were going to make money we sort of set
a time window on these things like all
right we don't necessarily agree about
whether we should sell virtual goods to
our users or do brand and sell
advertising on the site but we're going
to pick one and that might be influenced
by who's actually going to spend the
time to work on it and then give
ourselves a window to prove that out as
in that you know within that window of
time and that you know at least there's
an agreement around that and then after
that point and go back and like all
right we totally failed at this like
what do you want to do now let's go back
or let's continue we can sort of
evaluate it but to give yourself that
that framework I think is is one way to
solve it yeah this is one of the one of
the areas where I think you can learn
hyper learn conflict resolution there's
all sorts of ways to study how one does
it and um in my experience there's all
varieties of conflict but they end up
shaping your daily existence because
those are the things that stress you out
and the first step always in conflict
resolution my experience is you got to
get people focused on the right goal or
agenda in you know you can find
situations where people let their
self-interest get in front of the
company interest that's easy to spot and
that happens with directors where
directors say look you know I'd like to
sell the company or not sell the company
and and you have to say ok you have to
think about the shareholder here as a
third party this is a bit of the you
know the rauzein moment of you know
disinterest and say ok pretend like you
could be anybody what's the right thing
for the company in getting someone to
focus beyond themselves to that higher
good can really be an antiseptic for
most of the problems that emerge the
bigger issues in conflict I think come
up between executives that are peers in
you know this is routine problem where
engineering wants X product wants Y
sales 1z in it you know
bawd what we do in working with the CEO
is to help them be the hinge between
those executives in there's this moment
that occurs on a great executive team
where they feel shared interlocking
objectives and when you see that it's
like a soccer team moving in perfect
flight you say something special
happened here so it's rare and when you
don't see it you say okay well you guys
got to get on the same page and it's
very clear from this board meeting
you've got conflict that's you know
being talked about but a lot of it not
talked about where there's passive
aggressiveness and so but by trying to
get the foreground more clear and saying
these are the things we're committed to
beyond ourselves here's all I have to be
successful by making that other person
successful and here's what they have to
do to make me successful they're
interlocking dependencies you start to
move above the two individuals going at
each other's throat but it's it's a it
sort of defines our existence and so
there's not a single answer I can give
other than you know you can study it and
study it aggressively and I think it
serves you well the other thing is I
think you need to start with the
assumption that it is better to move in
a direction versus not to move at all
right so if you have a one vector one
person wants to go this way other
vectors is when you're not moving like
that is the worst state to be in like a
state of inaction at least it's better
to go in that direction somehow like so
I think we have that understanding so we
when we get into a gridlock it's like
okay we have to solve this because the
worst possible thing is to continue to
be arguing about it forever
this this thing just right one of the
traits of successful first time CEOs and
actually one of the death mills is
decision making in a lot of times people
could become to the Royal seat yo
because they're smart ever in this room
smart does well likes to think about
complex problems making a decision
something different and intelligence can
at times be an enemy for decision-making
because there's always what-if in CEOs
that freeze and decision making very
quickly create politics on our team
because if they can't decide the team
says well I have to use different means
of influence because I'm not getting any
direction from the CEO anytime so you
said look on the CEO iodized I don't
know if I want to pick but it turns out
it just as just says if you don't make a
decision and give a direction then those
problems will bloom them into something
much worse and so it's sealed there's
comments from field generals and
generals at war saying better to make
you know a hundred decisions and have 50
you want to be right and 49 wrong than
to make one decision a day and I think
that absolute rules for a CEO because
you just never have nothing formation
you move really fast yeah but
so my question was that you talked about
like while starting up you should think
about like having an idea that you're
really passionate about but at the same
time not start a company alone like a
pro founders so what like how is the
process of finding a co-founder with a
special like health as passionate about
the idea as you are and like what are
the other quality is apart from fashion
for the idea and the product that you
should look for in a co-founder so I
because I was at Google
I got exposure to a ton of people who I
would consider like hey we really get
along we work together we think the same
way about product design right so I was
able to meet a lot of people who I could
consider starting a company with so be
that's one reason to go to a larger
environment first then I think the other
thing that I've heard about I don't know
how successful it is is this thing
called founder dating where you just
sort of go to this mixer with all these
people who want to start companies and
sort of get to know people I've no idea
at work but that's what I've heard in
terms of what to look for in addition to
having passionate about the same thing I
think you have to make sure you're
motivated the same way and you have the
same philosophy around the core whatever
is going to be the core of the company
like an example of like philosophy
mismatch is if you think all right I
want to run I want this to be a product
engineering driven company and the other
person like men and I want this to be a
sales business a business development
driven company like that is a poor
mismatch that may like break you guys
apart at some point so you have to
screen for for those kinds of things
like philosophical stuff or if one
person especially if it's two
engineering people one is like alright
we just need to do whatever we need to
do to get it done
Facebook move fast and break things like
the willingness to break things like you
just got to move quickly and I don't
let's hack a little bit or you you know
if you put that with Apple people who
are more like noter happy perfect don't
release it until it's perfect like that
is a definite full of philosophy
mismatch and that's going to cause major
problems for the two founders so if the
screen for the things that are like your
core values what one thing I found
seeing the best companies best companies
always have more than one person where
it's not a it's somebody's the external
world thinks it's all person X but I've
a lot lately first time CEOs that fail
that go on and do it a second time and
succeed and there are many examples we
can point to obviously Steve Jobs but
there's a long list of them studying
what is the a/b test tell you what do
they do differently the second time and
a common theme and if it is it is the
theme is acute self-awareness the second
time around they say I'm not this this
and this so I'd better find that in my
partner in if you're not a great master
of execution you can't assume that
you're going to micromanage your way
through scaling a business and so I have
an example now a company I'm an investor
and New Relic where Lou the second time
around Lou said I need my co-founder
needs to be a guy that can run
engineering because I'd love to id8 I'd
love to create these things but if I
have to run engineering day-to-day and
then he came he said look I need a guy
who can run scale sales so that acute
self awareness where these three vectors
of leadership we talk about vision
relationship skills and execution skills
it's I haven't seen somebody that pegs
the top of all three of those you're
probably long one short one and medium
on the other so that self-awareness and
identifying okay what am I really good
at what am I not good at mapping your
co-founder onto that means you don't end
in a situation where you have two
founders that want to be the visionaries
that doesn't work one of them will be
the company if the company successful
over a period of time and so that acute
self-awareness is this this is the a/b
test which what do you learn from
somebody gets it right the second time
and versus the first time and that's
part of the learning process time for
one more question
how do you blueprint with decisions how
do you blueprint good decisions yes well
the the way we we try to drive the
strategy at Polyvore is we have clear
overarching goals of what we need to do
like these are this is where the company
is trying to go and this is in
particular the metric or trying to move
so if you take the subjectiveness out of
the question right so you're like all
right the metric we're trying to move is
number of transactions that Polly board
drives a date let's say we pick that
then you give that to the team and say
this is the number you're trying to move
and you can actually clearly see whether
they're doing well or not and after that
we usually set aside like a list of
projects that you think will move that
move the needle on that metric and you
know we may be wrong you might set that
at the beginning of the quarter in the
end we've done something completely
different but as long as the team is
still move that metric that's success so
I think you have to structure the teams
in such a way where everyone has a clear
set of goals are trying to hit that are
actually measurable and that takes a lot
of the the day-to-day decision-making
becomes much more clearer because if
you're working on something you like
should we do this I don't know if it's
going to work you can just try to test
for that or yeah try it you can evaluate
it based on that that metric does that
answer your question in a venture
business we make decisions in all sorts
of ways I would tell you new investment
decisions it needs to feel there needs
to be something in that decision that
feels really uneasy and it sounds
counterintuitive but I look back to our
investment in uber boy the total
addressable market for black cars and at
a price point to do bruh had we thought
it could be a tiny market at the time
there were maybe 600 black cars in San
Francisco that were licensed that we
could do bruh could tap into and you had
to take this huge leap of faith that you
could expand the market and at the
moment I don't know what numbers they've
published but it's there already more
black cars on the street at this point
in time and there were total license
black cars in San Francisco the time we
invested in any great investment has
of just counterintuitive angst and the
fact that you still want to do it
despite that tells me the blueprint of
that decision was right because if we
just did the obvious things in the
venture business we'd be making iPads
and get killed by Apple Polyvore boy it
was not obvious in um it may still be
itself but I think I think that's it
yeah thank you on behalf of GA basis and
SVP would like to present you with this
membrillo
thank you for coming
you